ECCLUSION.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE AN ON AIR
EXCHANGE SLIPS THROUGH THE
CRACKS ON ANOTHER NETWORK THAT
IS WORTH WATCHING.
SUCH WAS THE CASE ON CNN ON
POINT AND COUNTERPOINT ON
CRITICAL RACE THEORY.
>> SCHOOLS ARE RADICALIZING OUR
KIDS.
THIS IS THE VOLUME OF THE BOOK
IN CRITICAL RACE THEORY FOR LAW
SCHOOL BUT THIS IS GOING DOWN TO
YOUNGER KIDS LIKE WOKE BABIES
AND THERE IS A GRAPHIC SYMBOL OF
PEDOPHILIA.
>> Laura: SHE CAME ARMED WITH AN
IRREFUTABLE CONFRONTATION THAT
LEFT THE HOST GASPING.
A GUY WHO WORKS THE INCLUSION
RACKET IN AUNT, TEXAS.
-- AUSTIN, TEXAS.
TELLING COMPANIES TO GET PAST
THEIR OBSESSION WITH LUCRATIVE
HIRING.
HE PULLED A TERRY MCAULIFFE
SAYING PARENTS SHOULD STOP
BUTTING IN AND LEAVE EDUCATION
TO EXPERTS LIKE HIM.
>> TOO MANY PEOPLE KNOW LITTLE
OR NOTHING ABOUT EDUCATION
TRYING TO TELL PROFESSIONALS WHO
ARE WORKING HARD, WE ARE COMING
IN AS WEEKEND WARRIORS TO TELL
THEM WHAT EDUCATION SHOULD LOOK
LIKE.
THEY NEED TO PUT MORE TRUST IN
OUR EDUCATORS BECAUSE THEY SPENT
THE TIME AND ENERGY NECESSARY TO
UNDERSTAND THE NUANCES THAT ARE
BLOWN OVER HERE IN IN
CONVERSATION.
>> Laura: WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
WELL, IT MEANS IT'S NOT YOURS TO
QUESTION.
THESE TOPICS ARE TOO COMPLEX FOR
THE LITTLE PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND.
WHAT IS THERE TO UNDERSTAND
ABOUT READING TO CHILDREN THAT
ASSOCIATES WHITE PEOPLE WITH THE
DEVIL?
>> IT LITERALLY SAYS HERE
WHITENESS IS A BAD DEAL.
IT HAS A SYMBOL OF SATAN.
CHILDREN ARE GETTING THIS BOOK.
I AM A MUSLIM AND IMMIGRANT AND
A MOM OF COLOR.
I AM A SINGLE MOM, AND YET I
DENY ALL OF THESE PRIVILEGES IN
THE PARADIGM OF THE OPPRESSION
MATRIX BECAUSE WE ARE ALL HUMAN
BEINGS.
>> Laura: HE IS HIGHLY EDUCATED
AND A MINORITY DOESN'T MATTER.
-- SHE.
ALL THAT MATTERS IS MARKETING
GUILT AND SHAME TO SCHOOLS,
CORPORATIONS AND ENTERTAINERS
AND SPORTS FIGURES AND THE
CHURCHES ARE IN ON THE ACT.
EACH COMES UNDER ENORMOUS
PRESSURE TO COMPLY.
THEY PROVED THEY ARE BONIFIED BY
LINKING TO GOOFY POSTERS LIKE
THIS ONE AND SHUNNING ANYONE WHO
REFUSES TO MOUTH THEIR
PLATITUDES OR QUESTIONS THEIR
GOALS.
THE DEI MUST NEVER BE QUESTIONED
BY THE UNENLIGHTENED MASSS.
>> THIS DOESN'T SPEAK TO THE
LEVEL OF SOPHISTICATION THAT IS
NECESSARY TO HELP YOUNG PEOPLE
PREPARE FOR THE WORLD OF WORK
AND SOCIETY THEY WILL BE LIVING
IN.
WE HAVE TOO MANY OPPORTUNITIES
COMING TO THE UNIVERSITIES WHO
HAD LITTLE OR NO EXPERIENCE OF
KNOWING HOW TO NAVIGATE THE
CONVERSATION AND RELATIONSHIPS
RELATED TO RACE.
>> Laura: WHAT GIBBERISH.
DON'T YOU FEEL BETTER ABOUT
PAYING THAT FAT COLLEGE TUITION
NOW.
YOU MAY NOT KNOW IT.
SCHOOLS AND BUSINESSES ARE
DESPERATE TO CHECK THE EQUITY
INCLUSION BOX.
THEY FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE TO HIRE
RANDOM CONSULTANTS THEY FIND ON
THE WEB.
THIS IS THE FOUNDER OF A FIRM
DESCRIBED AS A DEI FIRM.
>> I THINK WHITENESS.
TALKING ABOUT THE EMBODIMENT OF
WHITE ANGRY  -- ANGLO WAVES OF
BEHAVE IN
BEHAVING [INAUDIBLE].
THE CONNECTION BETWEEN RACISM
AND WHITE SUPREMACY IS THAT
RACISM IS A MANIFESTATION OF
WHITE SUPREMACY.
>> Laura: WHAT A TERRIBLE WAY TO
MAKE A LIVING.
NO REAL KNOWLEDGE OF HISTORY.
ZERO APPRECIATION OF THE GREAT
BLESSINGS OF LIBERTY AND
OPPORTUNITY THAT AMERICA
PROVIDES.
ONLY RESENTMENT POLITICS AND A
LOT OF HAND MOVEMENT.
THE POINT IS TO TURN NEIGHBOR
AGAINST NEIGHBOR AND CITIZEN
AGAINST COUNTRY.
>> THE WHITE POPULACE HAS ALWAYS
BEEN SUSCEPTIBLE TO MANIPULATION
AROUND RACE.
>> THIS IS ABOUT WHITE CHILDREN
BEING EXPOSED TO IDEAS THAT WERE
SEGREGATED.
>> Laura: IF YOUR CHILDREN'S
SCHOOL TEACHES THIS NONSENSE,
DEMAND THAT YOUR SON OR DAUGHTER
BE ABLE TO OPT OUT.
THE GOALS ARE ALWAYS SHIFTING
FOR THE DEI.
20 YEARS AGO IT WAS TOLERANCE
FOR DIFFERENT POINTS OF VIEWS.
THAT DIDN'T GET THE FAR LEFT
ANYWHERE.
THEY SHIFTED TO DEMANDING
DIVERSITY.
THAT TOO WAS LIMITING.
THEY MOVED ON AGAIN.
A LECTURURE TALKED TO A PACKED
AUDITORIUM ON HOW TO ESTABLISH
THROUGH RACISM AND GENDER EQUITY
IN YOUR WORKPLACE.
>> THE GOAL IS NOT DIVERSITY.
THE GOAL IS EQUITY.
>> [CHEERING].
>> INSTEAD OF SAYING YOU ARE
GOING TO FORM A DIVERSITY
COMMITTEE, HIRE OUTSIDE EXPERTS
TO HELP YOU AUDIT AND ACHIEVER
EQUITY IF SALARYS AND
PROMOTIONS.
YOU CAN DO IT IN 2 YEARS.
>> Laura: SHE IS SCHILLING FOR
HER OWN INDUSTRY.
THE TEMPTATION IS TO LAUGH AT
THIS COTTAGE INDUSTRY.
BUT THAT'S A MISTAKE.
REAL RACISM IS REPUGNANT AND
EVERYONE BUT THE LOWEST OF THE
LOW KNOW IT.
WHAT WE ARE DOING TO OUR SCHOOLS
AND WORKPLACES AND EVERY DAY
LIVES IS DIVISIVE.
THE ONLY PEOPLE WE HELP BY
PROMOTING PEOPLE BASED ON
IMMUTABLE CHARACTERISTICS ARE
THE PEOPLE GETTING RICH OFF OF
TEACHING THIS.
REMEMBER, THEY ARE NOT ALONE.
EVERY PIECE OF THIS GARBAGE THAT
THE HARD LEFT ESPOUSES IS
TREATED AS GOSPEL BY PRESIDENT
BIDEN AND HIS TEAM.
>> AMERICA HAS A LONG HISTORY OF
SYSTEMIC RACISM.
>> SYSTEMIC RACISM IS A STAIN ON
OUR NATION'S SOUL.
A KNEE ON THE NECK OF BLACK
AMERICANS.
>> CLOSE THE ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL
GASPS THAT PERSIST BASED ON RACE
AND GENDER.
>> Laura: THEY WILL USE EVERY
BIT OF THEIR POWER AND THAT'S A
LOT OF POWER TO FORCE TO YOU
LIVE IN A COUNTRY DOMINATED BY
THE DEI POLICE.
THAT TAKES US BACK TO THE
DISCUSSION THAT CAUGHT MY
ATTENTION EARLIER TODAY.
WHAT A GREAT COUNTRY IT IS THAT
A MUSLIM-AMERICAN WOMAN WHO
ARRIVED HERE NOT SPEAKING OUR
LANGUAGE IS BETTER VERSED IN THE
GUARANTEES OF OUR CONSTITUTION
THAN COUNTLESS NATIVE-BORN DEI
EXPERTS AND THE BAFOON OCCUPYING
THE WHITE HOUSE.
THINK OF THE TENS OF MILLIONS OF
IMMIGRANTS WHO BECAME SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS AND DID SO
WITHOUT RELYING ON GOVERNMENT
HAND OUT OR DEI MANDATES TO
CLEAR A PATH FOR THEMSELVES.
JUST MAYBE IT'S TIME FOR US TO
FOCUS MORE ON PARENTING AND LESS
ON COMPLAINING.
MORE ON SHOWCASING TALENT A